casey had had this sort of experience
before
but never quite like this it wasn't a
panic attack per se
but certainly somewhere in the same vein
of experience
a moment where everything he understood
and felt to be true
started to crack and peel back the world
shedding its skin
and revealing an entirely new image of
itself to him
casey had just finished watching another
video on the topic
of free will or more specifically the
lack thereof
up until more recently casey never
really paid much interest to this
or any similar kind of topic that sort
of stuff always seemed distant
abstract and unnecessary to him of
course he had free will
he felt it in every moment what could
possibly be the issue or question
but more recently as he had become
slightly older and more curious
he found it a bit harder to see things
so simply and find meaning so easily
consequently he had become more
interested in topics of philosophy
looking further into different ideas in
attempts of better self-understanding
and ways of life and now after having
finished this last video
casey began to question the obviousness
of his own
free will specifically
the video was about the concept of
determinism which argues that all events
including human actions are determined
exclusively by prior causes
it argues for this by claiming that
since all particles and phenomena in the
universe
operate off of cause and effect patterns
in which there is always a continual
chain of preceding explanations
then like all other things in the
universe so too are human action and
choice
subject to the same deterministic system
logically this made complete sense to
casey he did not choose the parents he
was born to
where he was born the brain or genetics
he was born with
nor the first thoughts and experiences
he had and yet
these things directly affected and led
to every thought and experience he had
thereafter
in an unbroken linear sequence of cause
and effect
a cascading of forces in circumstances
that he was not in control of
nor totally aware of at any point and
thus
every new spur thereafter everything
that felt like his choosing
was yet another product of some causal
fixed thing that he didn't choose
beforehand
as a sort of cliche attempt at a witty
example the video he just watched even
said within the video itself
how he clicked on the video without
choosing all as a result of the sequence
of events tracking back to and beyond
his birth
the advent of the internet the invention
of the computer
the formation of the earth all the way
back to the beginning of the universe
fundamentally casey agreed with this
premise of determinism
but he struggled to see how its
implications could possibly be true
he struggled to agree with the idea that
he himself
did not have the free will that he felt
in every moment
and in this case he experienced the
intense disorienting dissonance
that occurs when a truth that one feels
intuitively
confronts and contradicts with the truth
that one knows logically
and his intuition fought back he
wondered to himself what could possibly
be the point of life if this were true
the video he just watched seemed to
claim that he could still choose to
enjoy life and find meaning in it
but how what sense did this make how
could he choose anything now
how can you reconcile the belief that
all of existence is deterministic
with the belief that you can find your
own meaning in the absurdity
it mustn't be completely true then casey
rationalized in his head
over the following several days casey
considered and tried a number of
different things in a hopeful effort to
prove this to himself
to find a flaw in the argument against
free will
on the tuesday of that week on his way
home from work casey stopped at a small
park not far from his apartment
to get some fresh air and relax for a
little he sat on a bench
looking out at the pond and people flow
around the park
ruminating to himself eventually still
struggling to shake the topic off the
surface of his mind
casey found himself thinking about the
concept of free will again
he considered how in this moment he and
he alone
wanted to stop at the park there was no
specific reason or event that caused him
to do so
no biological or physiological necessity
no external force
nothing other than his own willful
desire he wanted to stop at the park
and so he chose to and since he chose to
he did
how was this not free will he wandered
to himself
while continuing to think back and forth
a park goer's dog happened to run up to
where casey was sitting
sniffing the ground around him profusely
after circling around casey a couple of
times
the dog went on in the other direction
continuing to sniff and follow its nose
as casey amusingly observed the dog he
considered to himself if the dog had any
free will
clearly the dog wanted to find what it
was smelling and it was choosing to
follow what it wanted
but was it choosing to want what it was
smelling no
casey obviously concluded it was being
pulled by a desire that it had no say in
of course casey knew that he was at
least some good amount more conscious
than the dog
but did this fundamentally allow him to
decide what he did or didn't want
any more than the dog he could choose to
do what he wanted
but could he choose to want what he
wanted
sure he chose to go to the park because
he wanted to
but why did he want to he reflected on
where this desire came from
and couldn't find anything other than a
void it simply emerged into his
consciousness from some unknown stream
of events
and information and thoughts and desires
that he was mostly unaware of and did
not control
if he could have wanted to want to go to
the park wouldn't he have also had to
have wanted to want to want to
and then he would have had to have
wanted to want to want
to want to and so on and so forth into
infinity
which of course he did not and could not
have done
in truth he concluded he was no
different than the dog being pulled by
its nose
conditioned by the treats it finds along
the way
he was sitting at the park under no free
will of his own
three days later on friday night casey
was out getting dinner and drinks with a
few friends
once they were sat at the restaurant
casey decided fairly quickly what he
wanted to order
honey barbecue chicken wings while he
waited for the rest of the group to
decide what they wanted
casey ruminated in his head about this
and that
at some point of course the topic
emerged again
and casey suddenly had the idea to try
something to choose to order something
else that he didn't
and wouldn't ever actually want to eat
surely he thought to himself
since i'd be doing what i don't want for
no reason without being forced to by
anyone or anything other than myself
i'd be acting on my own free will and
overriding any deterministic sequence
logically in this moment this made great
sense to casey
and so when the waiter came he ordered a
completely different fish meal that he
had no desire to eat
when he did knowing that it was
something casey didn't like
two of his friends reacted with surprise
one asked him if he liked fish now
casey trying not to sound too crazy
briefly explained to them why he ordered
what he did
inevitably he sounded pretty crazy after
briefly discussing the idea together
casually one of his friends said but
technically didn't you still do what you
wanted
this simple question shut the whole
thing down for casey
he immediately realized his friend was
right in truth
he wanted to prove his sense of free
will to himself more than he wanted to
order a meal that he would have
otherwise wanted to eat
this although convoluted was just
another want that he didn't ultimately
choose
why he wanted to prove his free will in
this moment more than getting the meal
casey could not say it emerged the same
way as all other desires
a result of all the information and
thoughts and qualities of his
temperament
leading up to that moment going all the
way back to his birth
and beyond and so this attempt to escape
the cause and effect sequence
was itself determined by the very same
sequence
in trying to escape the system and prove
he had free will
casey only stepped forward right into it
revealing that he did not
the only difference was now he had a
meal he didn't want
[Music]
on the following monday on his way to
work casey stopped at a local coffee
shop
upon ordering the barista asked casey if
he wanted cream or sugar in his coffee
for some reason this question suddenly
spurred an insight and idea in casey's
mind
somewhat awkwardly he replied i don't
know
and then waited to see what would happen
naturally the barista paused and waited
in confusion
assuming casey would follow through and
make the decision
casey did nothing after a few extra long
seconds
in order to finally cut the moment the
barista spoke up and said
wait so you don't want them or you don't
know if you want them
after another brief pause casey replied
yeah you just pick it doesn't really
work like that
the barista replied with a somewhat
impatient confusion
you either want cream and sugar or you
don't casey
thinking about how foolish this
statement sounded to him now
took a coin out of the little tip
container on the counter flipped it into
the air
and caught it he saw that it landed
heads on his hand
and then clumsily said no creamer sugar
sorry thank you and put the coin back
into the container
while waiting for his order casey
considered how since he had left the
decision up to chance
the outcome was totally random not
determined by any cause and effect
sequence
nor any internal or external force
leading up to the outcome
for the moment he felt an excited sense
that he was perhaps onto something
a breaking of the whole system
during the rest of his drive to work
casey drank some of his coffee
wishing he had gotten cream and sugar it
didn't take more than a few sips for him
to realize the absurdity of what he just
did
he wanted cream and sugar but got black
coffee
where was the free will in that he had
no say in the random outcome of the coin
flip
and so sure it was random but how could
there be any free will and randomness
if anything he realized this encounter
with the barista
was only an elaborate example of even
less free will
with just some additional awkwardness
and no cream or sugar
as more days passed casey found himself
incapable of finding any loopholes
any cases where he could conclusively
find examples of the free will
that he once felt and knew he had he
watched countless videos
read books and essays on the topic and
so on
at this point he found it nearly
impossible to deny
the sense that he was the controlling
force of his life it seemed
was in fact an illusion and this was no
longer some abstract idea
now he felt it clearly and totally the
switch clicked
and the world looked different the
weight of this troublesome truth
hit casey fairly hard as it fell down
onto his shoulders
he now found himself in the unfortunate
position that afflicts all human beings
he couldn't unknow what he now knew even
if he wanted to
he couldn't go back to ignorance
ignorance is certainly not a choice
one cannot choose to truly be ignorant
of what they already know
for this would require they didn't know
it to begin with
and casey realized now that he never
even really had a choice in knowing what
he did or didn't
at all that night he experienced what
can only be described as one of the
hardest existential crises he'd yet
experienced in his life he struggled to
see any point anymore
any meaning this built up so heavily
that later that same night
casey decided to essentially stop caring
stop trying
stop doing anything really after all
since he was never really doing anything
to begin with
what difference would this make he
thought
for the rest of the night he sat on his
couch and stared at the wall
with no intention of intentionally doing
anything else
a renunciation of his life in a radical
act of complete fatalism
after several hours of sitting around
midnight casey got kind of hungry
naturally after tolerating the hunger
for as long as he could he got up and
made himself a grilled cheese sandwich
with a little pizza sauce
then he returned to the couch and ate it
he enjoyed it thoroughly
at around 12 55 he felt that he had to
use the bathroom
and naturally after no longer being able
to tolerate the feeling
he got up and went then he returned to
the couch
feeling much better eventually at around
2 45 a.m
casey became sufficiently tired and
dozed off to sleep
over the next couple days he continued
on sitting
trying to do nothing scrolling through
his phone most of the time
in between staring at the wall it took
no more than a day and a half
to begin to feel the absolute absurdity
of what he was doing
still weighed down by his sense of
pointlessness though he stayed put
acting as passively as he could
eventually the boredom and desire to do
something became so bad he took out a
video game
which he couldn't even remember the last
time he played
any video game for that matter he was
surprised the console even still worked
he started playing and quickly fell into
the game starting the story mode from
the beginning enjoying all the various
tasks and challenges along the way
before he even realized how long he was
playing for he finished the game
granted he had already played and beaten
the same game when he was younger
but nonetheless it still felt nice the
time seemed to fly right by
as you watched the final scene of the
video game story conclude
in the sort of corny typical video game
tone one of the characters said
everything is mostly sorted out now
couldn't have done it without you
not a total happy ending but good enough
between all the time casey had to think
over the last two days
and this line in the video game in this
moment it hit casey
the missing piece that put the whole
thing back together he realized he had
just thoroughly enjoyed a video game
that he knew was fake and had already
played all of the challenges in the game
were predetermined and pre-coded
and the game operated with specific
borders rules and controls
that all work towards a story that
essentially had just one single path
to one single predetermined end casey
fundamentally had no control over how
the game was played and where it went
he was just following the storyline as
it already existed
experiencing the illusion of him
actually creating and performing it
and yet despite this and his knowledge
of it there he had been
totally and fully immersed enjoying and
finding meaning in it the whole way
through
and his active participation was
entirely necessary to the experience
and the game playing through casey
realized to himself
there was no other way to live there was
no escaping the illusion if the illusion
was him
but there was no need to knowing
something is an illusion
does not stop the illusion from working
illusions are illusions
because they work i am not my
perceptions he thought to himself
not my choices not my actions but i am
still the experiencer of the whole
an observer of a consciousness that can
observe and navigate and find meaning in
the world
the greatest and most beautiful illusion
ever created and experienced
and i have a front row seat to it
nothing changes
the illusion is real
not too long after this moment one of
casey's friends called him and asked if
he wanted to meet him and a few friends
at a local bar
casey said he did and within the hour he
got ready
left his apartment met up with his
friends and enjoyed the rest of the
night
the same as he always had
[Music]
you